كله كوم ولما امك تموت معك كوم هذا اصعب
لحظه في حياه البشر خميس بكر صياد صار
معنا ما انتم شفتوا اللي صار معنا حرب
طاحن معسكر الشاطي كله راح الشيخ رضوان
راحت بيت حنون راحت مضلش حاجه بعد 33 يوم
بقينا ننام في المستشفى لما ضربوا قسم
الولاده صبحت نص العالم طلعت و وهاجرت انا
روحت على الدار لقيت لحاله في قلب حطيتها
على كتفه وزي باقي زي بقيه البشر وضلت ني
طالع فيها وين رحت فيها اول ما جيت اجيت
على جامعه حمد المفتوحه بس هي ما كملت معي
الطريق مع الشوب وخافت من الدبابه ومره
كبيره على جسر ود غزه طلعت روحها لانه كان
يوم ماساه وفي الطريق ماتت معي على الجسر
كيف ماتت خوف
ورعب مراه كبيره زي هذه مسنه اصعب لحظه في
حياه البشر لما يم الواحد بتموت معه
كانت نفسها تشوف اولاد اولادها واولادها
احسن ناس في الدنيا ك كل ام تشوفهم
مبسوطين وعايشين امزك الام وضحى وربت زلام
ابويا انجلط وهو صغير كافحت وربت زلام
وربت ست زلام وطلعوا زلام وربوا زلام اخر
ثلاث كلمات قالتلي اياهم وتخت انا بدي
اطلع كل من بده يطلع بده يموت قت من بده
يهاجر بده
موت